nuestro maestro poner el libro de texto
sobre el proyector para que todos
pudiéramos verlo como que nos sentábamos
y hacíamos diferentes secciones soy una
soñadora así que me distraigo a veces
hacíamos la lección y luego nos dejaban
tarea siempre había un cuestionario al
final de cada sección si así era antes
solía sacar ochos todo el tiempo pero
khan academy me ha llevado hasta el 10 y
eso es muy padre la forma en la que uso
khan academy
los ejercicios y eso me ayuda a mejorar
mis habilidades matemáticas veo los
videos si tengo problemas con algún
ejercicio
y logró tener una racha de 10 es ella
puede ver lo que estás haciendo así que
si estás perdiendo el tiempo ella solo
te dirá que hagas estos problemas y si
estás batallando mucho ella te ayudará
si no entiendes lo que el vídeo pide que
harás me gusta porque es diferente a
nuestro libro de matemáticas en el que
todos estamos haciendo lo mismo y si uno
sabe más es aburrido pero si el nivel es
muy alto nadie entiende nada antes tenía
miedo de preguntar cuando estaba
batallando y ahora que puede ver cómo
vamos en khan academy eso me hace sentir
más cómoda cuando hablo con ella sobre
mis dudas puedes ir a tu propio ritmo
porque hay todo tipo de ejercicios
desafiantes y ejercicios fáciles es muy
divertido porque puedes ganar insignias
y puedes letarte y hacer diferentes
tipos de matemática sin signos de
meteoro luna tierra sol y hoyo negro no
recordaba muy bien los exponentes aunque
los hice una vez
no recordaba mucho y luego vi el vídeo y
ahora se exponentes son muy fáciles el
que los hace sal enseña la materia muy
bien
y se escriben de la computadora porque
se ve el más pequeño y habla por el
micrófono y explica todas las materias
de esa forma y lo hace muy fácil de
aprender mis padres piensan que es muy
bueno y creen que es buena idea que haga
este sitio y lo bueno es que no tenemos
que estar en la escuela para aprender
podemos estar en casa en nuestras
computadoras
simplemente
a mí me gusta mucho cuando termino uno
de los difíciles es una herramienta de
vida todos necesitan saber cómo hacer
ciertas cosas de matemáticas no solo si
vas a ser un astrónomo tienes que saber
de todo una noche estaba trabajando en
una lección y no podía terminarla y mi
papá me dijo que no podía jugar con mis
amigos si no la terminaba
luego pude terminarla porque vi el vídeo
y realmente pude entenderlo